you know i hear people all the time
complain about their job they don't want
to have a job i'm like man you have to
love your job if you don't love your job
how are you going to go start a business
and have people that work for you that
don't hate their job it's a gift to be
able to have a job like if you can smile
i really believe this if i can smile
throughout my life even when i'm eating
like yeah okay what else you got i was
telling elena she was down there boxing
this morning and with javier and her
cooks are getting awesome and she had
this look on her face i said look you
gotta smile when you do that kick you
gotta smile when you punch you gotta
smile when you get punched because when
you can smile when you're eating taking
a bunch when things are not going well
when you're terrified and you can keep
smiling through it i think churchill
said when you're going through hell skip
move run and have a smile on your face
like it doesn't bother you and you
become dangerous to other people when
you can eat you're humble enough to say
yeah okay i'll do the vicious okay i'll
sweep the floors
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
rule number two focus on success
the first thing i might want to do
before i start planning new stuff
take some of this stuff out of my garden
i need to make some space
i need to make some space i need to
remove the weeds i need to mulch the
ground i need to take something out i
need to dig in remove stuff okay get the
soil
uh ready for new plants and new trees
and a lot of times and in fact every
time in my life
for me to get
for me to get from this place right here
where i am i'm parked right now
for me to get from here to there i have
to leave here
that is the number one rule of success
i have to give up something
and for me i've given up drugs i've
given up friends i gave up a girlfriend
that i was like madly madly in love with
crushed me for years i've done that two
of those
[Music]
they weren't right for me they just
weren't the right people for me i was in
love but
whatever chemistry
it deluded my power
i've given up
a house in houston texas where i had
friends and family i gave up a house in
la jolla that i absolutely loved still
loved today still missed that house
today
20 years i've been out of that house
miss it almost every day
had to give it up though to become this
guy
uh gave up a house elena and i gave up a
house in los angeles magnificent
magnificent house
you know i would flip my house where i
live today i would flip it off to go
live back in that house today
people don't understand the sacrifices
people pay every day
every day i still go to work today i
give up my free time to go to work
because i got 107 employees
that depend on me
for a paycheck
for inspiration
my company feels it when i'm not there i
know they feel it
johnny the camera guy starts missing me
you know the other guys start missing me
i got a great team too my team holds
everything together but
even when you're the the king you work
you you're the man the boss you're the
you're the the queen of the
of the empire
you're still working for other people
you still got to give up your freedom
and your right to do whatever you want
rule number three aim to get rich i
remember when i was a kid a man told me
he's like grant patience is a virtue and
i looked at him and said
are you trying to get a head start on me
because that's what it sounds like that
reminds me how many people say money
won't make you happy you know rich
people aren't happy look folks okay why
is this whole rich topic so sensitive to
so many people why is it so many people
the moment you say rich wealthy get rich
get wealthy the first thing that happens
everybody's like rich people they you
get all this negativity around being
rich rich people aren't happy rich
people are dysfunctional rich pedia rich
people are greedy rich people are
selfish you've heard all that
money won't make you happy why all the
disdain why the hate why the criticism
for the wealthy i'm not talking about
people that inherited their money i'm
talking about people that worked from
nothing and created an empire and
created true wealth that you can't
possibly get rid of in a lifetime people
that will actually create so much wealth
that they they'll leave it for
generations to come the duponts the
fords the carnegies bad people or did
they do something really big look when i
talk about getting rich i'm talking
about you
ra tapping into your full potential not
just financially but in all areas of
your life my family i'm rich
my company i'm rich my finances i'm rich
my bit my other businesses are rich not
just because they have money but because
they're rich in ideas rich in great
people rich in energy resources and
creativity man get rich man and if you
don't want to get rich please don't
blame other people that want to that's
the rant for the day rule number four
practice consistency how many times in
my life
[Music]
i've i've woken up like not sure
i think it started happening for me
uh
years ago like
like
probably around 12 or 13 i didn't know
what to do every day what's what's today
going to bring maybe it's after watching
so much tv and eating so much sugar you
know i think our diets definitely have a
lot to do with all that
but look i want to give you something
today about how to get out of the funk
the funky hunk dunk
when i by the time i was 25 this thing
went on from 12 to 25 at 25 years old i
was in so much depression every day i
was using drugs
alcohol i was self-medicating constantly
making bad decisions
i lived in a 275
i mean i just remember how much it was
it was 275 dollars a month and every
other month i couldn't make the bill the
payment i was late
today
i live in this joint right here
i live up on the 33rd floor of this
place
and
completely different life today than i
had then
25 i went to a treatment center for 20
28 days for drug addiction i was using
drugs every day hated it
let me tell you something worse than
drugs is how you feel about yourself i
hated myself every time i did a drug
every time i smoked weed every time
every time i did
any drug
the moment i put the pill in my mouth
the weed to my mouth something in my
nose
i hated myself
i never felt good
about using drugs
and so
by the time i was 25 i had been using
drugs for
10 years but my problem started before
that
my problems didn't start with the drugs
it started with my inability to manage
this
light grade chronic depression
this
for lack of better words this
this idea that i wasn't good enough this
idea that
that um
that um
i didn't love myself you know that that
you know
my mom gave my mom quit on me my mom
told me hey don't come around here
anymore my twin brother
pretty much
was done with me
my sisters both knew that i was in
trouble and were like oh my god you know
we're gonna get a call on him today
the people i worked with the principal
at the high school i went to said i
couldn't couldn't win dog catcher
in my 11th and 12th grade told my mom
that
my student
my pe teacher said i would amount to
nothing i wrecked my car on my driver's
ed test i failed my driver's license
test i was fired from my first six jobs
wouldn't leave the sixth one dude i'm
telling you i was a loser
loser okay i'm telling you loser and i
didn't have to ask other people nobody
had to tell me i was a loser i knew i
was a loser
so look if you've ever been there i know
there's people watching this right now
maybe you don't even know who i am
you're like who's this dude talking
about himself you know
i've come from that where i was bankrupt
spiritually financially physically i
weighed 134 pounds that's 40 pounds less
than i weigh today
i was broken every way possible i didn't
have any money i was in debt
but worst the worst thing the worst of
the worst of the worst
was how i felt about myself
i got out of that treatment center and
the counselor told me on the way out of
the treatment center if you read my last
book be obsessed or be average
it was the first book that i really
shared anything about my life
of all seven of my books that that one
gives you a
kind of a look inside my life more than
anything
and um
maybe what i'll do is in this maybe what
i'll do is i'll have my guys give you
give you a a a chapter of that book free
and um it's not what i came here to give
you i want to i do want to give you
something but maybe my guys can put a
couple of different links in here for
you
so
i got out of that treatment center and
the counselor said to me i think his
name was philip i don't remember the guy
now hated his guts then i still don't
think much of him he said to me guy was
really confused
he was more confused than i was
he said now that i look back he said to
me he said to me he said hey
if you leave here
if you leave here and you don't give up
you know because when you're there you
spill your guts tell them everything
and i told them i wanted to be rich and
famous and and help people and write
books and
you know be known all over the world he
says if you don't give all those ideas i
think he called it grandiosity if you
don't give up all these grandiose ideas
of changing the world
uh being rich being famous
if you don't change all those ideas
you'll never ever ever make it you'll
never stay
what do you call it you'll never stay
dry and sober
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five create your own
guidance if you're you're looking for uh
if you have money and you have health
and you don't have purpose
and you don't have interest and you
don't have excitement and you're not
waking up every day but like
like with like hey i'm looking forward
to getting to the gym and working out if
you don't have those things going on or
i'm gonna go on a vacation or i'm gonna
spend time with my grandkids or my kids
or
i'm gonna write a book or something
exciting if you don't have that you're
gonna burn okay so
first of all let me just say i don't
know everything i just know at 63 years
old i'm in the best shape of my life i'm
in the best financial condition of my
life and i'm the most excited i've ever
been in my entire life
that was not true
just uh
16 year 16 years ago 17 years ago
is that right 63 12 years ago i'm sorry
12 years ago it wasn't that was not true
i was stressed i was burnt
i had three employees
two and a half employees
and only half of those worked
and i was doing all the work i was
running all over the country i was doing
250 uh
days a year traveling picking up checks
i was a salesman basically i was a
i was a
uh
uh what's the word uh you know i was uh
was sales was out selling pitching on
planes
i was doing about uh 100 000 miles a
year on american and united
buying a coach ticket
crossing my fingers hoping for an
upgrade staying at the marriott on award
points you know the game right i was
away from my family
had a new family at the time i just got
married i was traveling every day my
quality of my life was terrible
and
i made a decision
to get off
a challenge myself to get off the
treadmill of that treadmill now i knew
that i couldn't get off that treadmill
if i didn't have something else to go to
so i started studying people that have
scaled their finances
i needed money to work for me
i didn't need to keep working for the
money i had a little bit of money put
away but i was terrified of it do you
know what i mean by the way if you run
into this channel for the first time one
more people are using the youtube
channels and the instagram people our
age are using it to access information i
dropped i've dropped about 5 000 videos
in this channel about sales marketing
starting over scaling health
finances
real estate
i started playing this real estate game
hard about 12 years ago i started
spending more time investing in real
estate than i did on picking up a sales
check
i started pulling away from some of the
old ideas that i had been sold as a kid
by the banks in wall street which was
diversified
retirement accounts 401ks iras i took my
ira and my 401k money that and it was
self-directed and i basically took
control of it and took it away from
fidelity and uh schwab and wall street i
took that money away from them a couple
things that i did i went and looked at
my money i had money in savings accounts
check-ins accounts money markets uh
where else i had some mutual funds i had
etfs i had 401ks and ira all of it
either sitting in money markets or
garbage paper stock
and i pulled all control of that money
back over i also had equity in a home
i grabbed the equity at home i sold the
home
and went rented i literally reworked the
entire finances of my life just keep
this in mind think about this you don't
have to go do it today and you don't
have to you don't have to be right or
wrong in this deal rule number six learn
how to scale how do i grow my business
10 times
not one or two times how could i scale
my business out so that i have maybe you
have 100 customers or 200 customers how
could i have 2 000 customers you got 2
000 how could i have 20 000 customers
this is what the big companies do you
got four employees that you don't like
how can i have 40 employees
and have somebody else handle
the 40 that i don't like
because what's happening right now is
people are scaling down when they should
be scaling up rule number seven never
take advice from a quitter if you don't
like your financial condition look at
your environment
my my financial condition has been an
indication of the people around me and
what i'm listening to every day if you
don't have something i'm not talking
about a book right now i'm talking about
you guys need to be buried in content
buried immersed how many of you heard
this the same
dream i'm drinking the kool-aid
you need to swim in it
you need to drown yourself in it you
need to immerse yourself inject it into
your arm you need to smell it breathe it
love it drink it immerse yourself in
whatever kool-aid you're going to drink
be all in no one's going to come to your
house and make your dreams come true it
won't happen it's not going to come
through the tv
not going to come to you on facebook
it's going to become because you have a
place to go
every day
and get your head right
your attitude right
how many believe you're an attitude
business first
oh wow
seven people
yeah i'm all in man i'm all in
how many you got people on your team
like this man yeah yeah man i'm gonna do
good man
i'm gonna do good i'm i'm going after
how many of you heard people building
teams say i can't find good people
yeah what's the point
why are you telling that to other people
why do you tell that to other people why
are you trying to make sense and not
finding good people you
get what you think and say every day
i can't find any good people seven
billion people on planet earth
you can't find good people because you
quit
you quit
[Music]
so you just need to know the truth when
you criticize anything you're saying
something about yourself see i don't get
rid of haters i i'm like come on man
bring it on dog tell me about yourself
you talk about money too much you ain't
got any
oh you work too hard you don't work hard
enough
you too cocky you ain't cocky enough
why are you going to blame my swag
because you ain't got any
huh
you left yours at somebody's house
somebody told you you were an introvert
you bought into it
right somebody said you're shy and you
bought into it somebody said you don't
need to have a business you don't need
all that you don't need a jet you don't
need the big house you don't need a
bunch of money do you gave up i didn't
keep it to yourself
you don't need to be contagious
okay people quit this organization and
what do they do oh yeah right what do
they say never write this down never
ever take advice from a quitter
if you quit anything
man i quit going to the gym it just
didn't work for me i don't need to hear
that from you
i'm going to get different information
from the people still going to the gym
would you agree look if you don't
believe in you enough to invest in
yourself every day i don't have time i
got the kids i got the wife i got the
marriage i got the problem i got the boy
scouts i got this dude you're sold on
something else i don't even know what
you're talking about right now
you're you're manufacturing
to contaminate other people i don't need
to hear about all your problems i don't
care rule number eight just get closer
if you're waking up today and you're not
feeling it i'm not talking about
workouts either whatever it is going to
work
making the call
cleaning up something that you have to
clean up
handling some problem that you have
and you're waking up feeling a little
depressed
kind of down
you know what i'm talking about just
don't quite feel it
but everybody expects me to be up all
the time thinks i'm supposed to
you know be mr
10x mr 100
every day
that is never the case
never
so look if you run into this channel for
the first time subscribe to it i'm going
to share three things that i do
to get me through this
then make sure you comment or like
i'm building this channel out i spent
the last 10 years building out with
content material
of things that i'm discovering in my
life and in my business
in hopes that it will help people
and
i don't have all the right answers
i just want you to know like
40 of the time i'm wrong
maybe a little more than that actually
even
i just got to be right on the big things
you know
and one thing that
that
has helped me
whether it was writing a book and
finishing it
or starting my speaking career when i
did it 30 years old i was going door to
door
to businesses around america
flew 3 million miles
go to city i was living in houston at
the time
in bel air texas and i'd fly to
salt lake city
and i'd call on business owners
i'd set a an event two weeks
in advance commit to the hotel
fly to salt lake city knew no one no one
knew me i had no name no books
there was no social media
and
i never felt like doing i was scared
today
had no clue what i was doing
didn't know who i was calling on
don't even know how much i believed in
what i was doing like
i did believe in it
but it was like
you know i didn't have any statistics or
facts or success stories
and
regardless of how i felt just like this
morning
regardless how much doubt there was or
uncertainty
fear
no matter who you're watching or who
you're following
whether it's
a political
person a
rapper movie star
teacher coach parents
i don't care how much in confidence they
put out how much athlete how much
confidence or
certainty that they push out push out
like like project
they wake up there's days they wake up
and they don't feel it they don't feel
it they don't they don't want to do it
they're uncertain
uh they're feeling some low-grade
depression whatever you want to call it
look i woke up like that this morning i
went
got up
family's not here this weekend
uh elena's got the kids she's teaching
how to shoot guns this weekend
and i'm here by myself so i'm waking up
this morning like i don't want to work
out i missed yesterday
i'm not feeling it
so what do you do
what do you guys do when you don't feel
it
so this is what i do i just get a little
closer
this is what i do i get a little closer
just like i did when i was 30 years old
starting my speaking career never
thought i'd be one of the top considered
one of the top
two or three speakers in the world when
i was 30 years old i wanted that
but i didn't know how i was going to get
to that
and what i did what when i was having to
fly to these cities salt lake city
winnipeg saskatoon toronto uh vancouver
chicago new york like i've never even
been to these places i was literally
flying to cities for the first time in
my entire career didn't know the
language didn't know the the culture
didn't know how they
they those little changes and
that happened between toronto and new
york new york and chicago chicago and
dallas and dallas and salt lake salt
lake and la those are all very very
different markets and different people
and different thinking
dude i was terrified
okay i'm doing this today to tell you i
was terrified i was
so scared most of the time that it felt
like not fear it felt like depression
like i wanted to take the fl the the
sheets just pull them over my head so
what i did
to conquer that to handle that
i literally would just get a little
closer and get myself a little closer to
the action like this morning i just got
close to the gym i actually wouldn't
walk by the pool i have a pool in the
same spot that we have a gym on the
second floor here and i walked out there
and as i passed the gym because they're
still doing the social distancing
[ __ ]
um
there was nobody in here i'm like okay
there's nobody in here it's a sign i'm
gonna go in there and work out okay so
number one just try get a little closer
to the action hope that helps you just
get a little closer you don't have to
commit to doing it completely just get
closer to it i came down here dressed
uh i put that i put that on before i
left so i was ready so i got a little
closer second thing do if it calls you
do it anyway
you know i coined this phrase years ago
do it anyway
a buddy of mine
about the same time i was starting my
business
i was having a lot of problems in my
life i was probably
it was before i started my business i
was still in houston texas i was going
through tremendous tremendous amounts of
uncertainty doubt about myself i was in
a transition a career transition just
lost a job
starting my deal
and
i went one year
one year
without working
i've never ever shared this before one
year and i did not i mean
i had a little bit of money saved and i
was going through it
i didn't i didn't literally i looked
like i was working every day but in
truth i was not working my twin brother
actually knew that and finally
confronted me and that's what got me off
my ass but
this guy told me he's like look you wake
up in the morning and no matter what
you're feeling
no matter how much you hurt
if your eyes are bleeding
do it anyway rule number nine master the
art of selling this financial statement
on this page is for companies
individuals
and households
every company a country a city every
company individuals you want to make a
note here
companies individuals and households
[Music]
okay if you're a household uh a bill
bill builds a household he's got a
household i know he's got a household
he's got to have a house i don't know
who's in the house his household has a
budget he's got income coming in
expenses going out that's a financial
statement that's what that is right
there income
uh uh less expenses equals what's left
over period in the story that could be
google facebook your house it could be a
company it could be a country it could
be a city they're all the same by the
way i go to canada japan i go to
singapore dubai detroit and the
financial statement will be identical
the language will change the financial
statements will be identical everywhere
you go the top line of every financial
statement for a household or a company
or a city is what
revenue income or sales okay this used
to be sales and then some account it how
many accountants in a room
some intelligent smart person
okay so we need to change that to like
to like revenue
it used to be simple sales
okay and then somebody's like oh we got
to call that something
better
okay we're going to call it revenue it
sounds more professional
dude it's sales okay how many of you
don't like sales
how many of you in a room let me see a
hand if you don't like sales okay if
you're no good at it you don't like it
so that means everybody in the room's a
damn masters sensei
how many of you love watching my guys on
on the on the uh on the uh on the up
here uh doing the sales thing dave todd
how good are those guys
are they good
and then i show up around 11 o'clock and
i show you a different variation you're
like dying doc
another level
you could be a black belt
that don't make you a sensei
right so like like i've done my thing
i've done my thing 30 years
there's a big difference between 30
years and six years
like i know every little crevice and i'm
still learning i know little little
angles
like one thing means a thousand things
to me not ten you understand because i
played the game a little longer so you
get deeper you get sensei
so there's a lot of levels to the game
man sales is about revenue folks if you
don't like sales
you want to write this down if you don't
like sales
you don't like revenue
so get a t-shirt
i hate revenue
i hate sales scratch it out but i hate
revenue
because if you don't like sales you're
in trouble at home you had trouble for
your city you're in trouble for your
community you're in trouble everywhere
if you don't like income
because you unlike the government can't
print money it's against the law that's
why the america the united states
government the only product the united
states government has
is the printing of money there is no
other product
they print money so you work
you work you'll never create wealth okay
you want to write this down well no
matter how hard you work
okay
kevin can work his ass off
he could work 20 hours a day
he will never create wealth working he
will only create wealth when he invests
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips is don't
be scared of change i'm about to move
i'm moving from los angeles california
where i've been 22 years in california
my wife's been here 23 years she came
here to be an actress at 17 years old
and we're picking up and we're moving
everything i wrote the governor a letter
three months ago and said dude you keep
raising my taxes i'm out of here by the
way you should be doing that you should
be thinking about hey how can i avoid
seven eight nine 10 or 11 state income
taxes most of you don't even know what
your income tax is you think when you
buy something sales tax is your income
tax i'm talking about the income tax you
pay on earned income that you earned
jerry brown didn't earn any of it so i
tell jerry brown i'm done dude if you
keep raising my taxes they're going in
that direction we're like okay we're out
of here
now i got to tell you man it is scary
moving it is terrifying to move i'm like
i'ma move to miami i'm going to live in
a new place we're going to rent a house
for a while we're going to figure out we
got to make new friends we don't know
anybody there all that stuff right
all the trouble figuring out the
calendar the money it costs to move all
that and then i'm like wait a minute
what are you worried about dude
you so pinned down to one place you
can't get up and move every once in a
while
it it reminds me how many people
don't want change the way it was is in
the past the way it's gonna be is in the
future so what is it gonna mean a lot of
trouble me and my wife the kids new
furniture new house new place new
friends i gotta talk these guys here at
the company hey guys a year from now
maybe two years from now we're gonna
shut this thing down in la and you guys
are gonna move over there with me but
look change is good don't be scared of
it you're not pinned down like like you
were like it's 400 years ago and you
lived in some village where they
convinced you that the world was flat
remember that i think that's why we get
scared of moving the world is flat don't
leave the village you'll fall off
no you won't you're just going to change
you're going to evolve you're going to
make new friends
dude if you need to pick up and go some
other place to make your life better
your family better to find great schools
to make more money pick your [ __ ] up and
move
all commitments require investments in
time and money all commitments
you cannot make a commitment without
time and money being invested
time and money has to be invested you
have to invest time and money
if it's not on your schedule you're not
committed if you don't have money back
by that time on your calendar if it's
not costing you money or you don't have
money deposited right there you are not
committed where you have your money is
where your personal spiritual emotional
physical commitments go wherever your
money is is who you are most committed
to
wells fargo bank of america citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
wells fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising the market
because you guys are committed to the
lie
the big marketing scam of the universe
save your money
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not bore
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too will be able to stay
at a holiday inn
for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there
and eat all you want for as long as you
want by the way
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the
belt that you bought and put on your
credit card
that you can't write off by them so this
is what americans are doing people all
around the world spend 40 hours a week
running around hustling
yeah they get 100 what do they do now
they run over here to the bank drop off
the hundred bucks then they run back out
and do another 40 weeks pick up a
thousand dollars man i had a great week
didn't i bang and then they run over
here and drop it off at the bank these
are the good americans
[Music]
the bad americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it the
good americans
run run around collecting a thousand
dollars five thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars hustlers hustlers man
hard workers they they get sophisticated
uh i'm gonna put a little money in the
bank over here over here at wells fargo
i'm gonna have a little over here at
citibank i'm gonna spread this
around
i want to be a slave to many
not a slave to a few
i'm gonna give a little to the bank of
america i'm gonna give a little bit of
citibank i'm gonna give a little bit to
the wells fargo i'm gonna give a little
bit to fidelity and merrill lynch i'm
gonna give a little bit to my ira and my
401k i'm gonna bust my ass i'm gonna
spend 40 years killing myself to make
sure all these institutions
have my money
where they pay me nothing
for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me up
hey mr cardone
[Music]
we got another dummy
guy spent god damn he must have spent
160 hours
put together a little bank extremely
disciplined dumbass
and and he
saved 100 thousand dollars with us and
we'd like to know mr cardone
if you would like to borrow that money
his money
yeah i sure would because we know mr
cardone that you will put that money to
work
okay
this guy that gave it to us all he wants
to do is work
i'm like yeah send me that money bro
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
gonna call nine other people
they're gonna take his 100 grand and
they're gonna save they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out
900 000
of it and this is the banking system
and that is debt by the way
that u.s dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you
people say the dumbest things it could
be family it could be your wife your
husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough i promise you will be what they
do okay so look at some of the dumb
things you say like this here's one dumb
thing people say
time heals all things
really
you get a splinter in your foot and you
don't pull the splinter out you don't
look at it confront it and say i gotta
pull that little
booger out i gotta pull that little
splinter out if you just leave it there
you might get used to it yeah you'll get
used to it 30 years goes by you still
got a splinter in your foot who knows
that splinter gets into your bloodstream
goes to your heart spikes your heart
kills you time does not heal all things
folks you know what heals all things
taking a look at it having the courage
to look at it hey what happened to me
how did i screw up here what what hurt
or what pain or what happened that i had
a loss i see people go through life with
all these losses unwilling to look at
them all crippled by the time they get
older not old but they looking old
because they believe that time heals
look time heals when you confront it
when you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what i'm saying because some of
the ideas you got they just dumb
and dumb things will cause you to do
dumb things the reason the guys on wall
street and the gals on wall street make
so much money
okay it's not because they're they're
they're like capitalists and they're
terrible people it's because they're
surrounded by people that are making
money man they're accountable by their
stock price they're accountable to their
production they got people around them
that expect them to win and do well and
also they're going to dinner waking up
at breakfast working out in the gym with
other people that are winning big in
life okay so you need feedback from your
environment and your network fourth
thing you need is you gotta have fifth
thing you need is you gotta have a
network of people that are encouraging
you
to kill it you got to have the right net
you got to have a lebron in your game
man if you're playing in the nba and
lebron's like i'm going to take you
under my wing bro
okay kobe's like hey man i want i'm
coming back to be with you man what
would you deny that okay michael jordan
i want to be with you man tiger woods i
want to golf with you come on guys what
are you doing you cannot do this alone
you cannot do this alone are you kidding
me man let's say you want to be a
surgeon and a top surgeon in the world
like i want to take you under my wing
what are you going to do i'm too busy
this isn't a magic act these are basic
skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most salespeople have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching
uh manipulation tactics
dodge the question
don't answer control the customer
uh the the whole newer linguistics bull
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro linguistics
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the lnlp stuff i'm
just telling you we've hired
hundreds and hundreds of sales people
i've been with tens of thousands of
sales people i have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bullet
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
i don't want drama dude i want
production
so
so when when he sits a certain way i
don't start thinking about man i'm
imagine being in a sales sales
presentation i'm like i got to be like
him and then now i got to be like her
and now i got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that
you
you man what a dis
i want to be me
the power resonates for me my truth my
authenticity and my transparency
okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it i never ask him to be
me i'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say
well i'm with you
everybody try that
no no i didn't say it like that i said
i'm with you
see and i'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high i knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay see i i'm he he gets to be him
but the words will work because all i'm
doing is basically agreeing with the
customer this isn't a trick here
okay uh this course is uh i'm doing a
dinner tonight for 25 000 at my house
okay i think we got two slots left
the entire 25 000
goes to the grant cardone foundation any
of you want to put 25 grand in please
see one of my people come have dinner at
my house we'll spend a couple hours over
there the money's going to go to help
kids some of you in a room immediately
say
oh my god 25 grand that's a lot of money
man i know that
you don't think i know 25 000 a lot of
money i'm the one that decided what the
freaking entry would be
i said what would be too much 25 grand
25 grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like damn that's a lot
of money okay and the people that it's a
lot of money that think small that go
small and don't want to help won't come
to my house and have dinner
and the people they're like dude i'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
grand get pictures with him at his new
home
with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and i get
to write it off i get to bang the irs
who hates the irs
well this is this is a chance to give
them a good friend
[Music]
okay so you see what i'm doing i'm
handling all the objections right now i
understand 25 grand a lot of money man i
know what you got to do to earn 25 grand
you got to do crazy stuff to earn 25
grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in a room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour
every business i have five companies now
we'll do a hundred million this year i
started every one of those companies
with no money zero money man just hustle
and grit and courage
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes
to make your dreams a reality to be
closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man
you're 32 years old you've been trying
to save money for 20 years and you
hadn't do it and do it now i don't need
anything special here i'm not going to
be empathetic
quit being stupid right to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
right i call it a a group called me
yesterday i'm actually trying to do a
deal with cnbc and the guy says i'm
interested i said good i'll be there
tomorrow call me back i'll be i'm flying
into new york tomorrow what am i trying
to do right now by the way i was
supposed to be here today
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work
i can't do tomorrow i was going to be
here anyway i'm trying to close the deal
let me close the deal i'll figure out
how to be in two places at one time
later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i can see you at four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at 4
o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
today
done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody'll understand
commit first they're going to rest out
later close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your counter's got the devil
all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
you don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target never lower a
target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower target be reasonable
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl
she says no he goes to another girl
right
gave up on his dream
if you're going to give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization for me like i was always
scared of money you know and and i was
terrified of it so so like if you look
at still today like i look at the bill
of everything
it's a bill of everything
if something caused something i want to
know how much it was
and so like
how much is it like i'm going to ask
that question
whether whether it matters or not um it
doesn't matter where i get in my life i
don't think i'm ever going to be free of
how much was that how much was the
dinner how much how much was dinner how
much was the tip how much was the code
how much was the jacket what did you
know me me and elena like elena's like
hey it's gonna be fine man like look
what look look
look at what you've done we cannot spend
this and i'm like how much was it
i want to know how much it was because
when i grew up do you had to know what
things cost
and so the point your question about
money is it's a terrifying thing because
it's the one thing in life
that
you know the nfl is not going to give me
the ball
and and i'm never going to get a chance
to golf i can't win in those
environments but with money
everybody gets money it's the one place
where everybody gets it and now what do
i do
and i could lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power you know very few of us ever ever
get any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
i do with this
you know am i going to do it am i going
to do the right things with it and so i
think people withhold themselves because
they don't we're not educated about
money we don't know where it comes from
we have a lot of misinformation about it
our parents terrified us
you know money doesn't grow in trees
uh save your money it'll save you all
these these these things our parents
told us because they were enamored
or are encumbered
with the same kind of liabilities around
money right i don't know how to get it
i don't know how to keep it
and the
the third the worst part that we're all
at is i don't know how to invest it yeah
so what i'll do is i'll some people get
good at getting it
very few actually fewer people at
keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in america
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know um
you know kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like i had an uncle he
buried everything you ever made they
were in the backyard wow
the other uncle was was uh he was he was
a guy that bought he he worked hard very
very frugal
italian descent
and he would uh buy real estate but it
was always buy low and sell high he
actually never sold anything but that
was the concept buy low by the cheapest
lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely frugal
my other uncle
was uh worked in a refinery he basically
saved all his money paid everything off
got out of debt that was their lifestyle
my dad died when i was 10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and so that's all i had
right everybody around me was like get
money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so i think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified
of this
this apparent
apparency of it's scarce right
and it's not
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it if you're
reading a book
okay you're listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in events it's
the 700th time you did that presentation
you got to show up new again
johnny comes to work with his camera and
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new you got to show up every day
new folks you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
[Music]
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterday's
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [ __ ] but it's got
to be fresh
i need some fresh [ __ ]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[ __ ] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either i'm making 2.4 million
dollars a year
if i could figure out how to get another
two hundred dollars that's called value
add v8 value ad if i could figure out
how to raise the rents 200 bucks
531 units
see that's why the number of units is so
apart
531
106 000
times what
is what one point
see that creates another 1 million
274 000 of income a year
i'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
bam
that traffic jam
[Music]
okay i got more cash flow
i just got i don't have to go work i
don't have to beat stuff up
i don't have to go uber you guys are
i'm going to go uber to what what you go
uber to
you end up with seven dollars
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
freedom
i don't want money this money i've had
this money here the whole time okay
it ain't gonna do anything
how many got money in the bank right now
it's useless
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money
and then they spend it and you're just
doing this thing
comes in it goes out
you have to have multiple exits on the
way out
how do i get out of this deal
i know people that have bought real
estate that they're like in cash flows
but they're like i cannot i can never
get rid of this piece of property it's
always going to be a problem for me hang
me around my neck
[Music]
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it i promise you you
will not lose money in this space
warren buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when i read that i'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do i invest
in oh invest in something that doesn't
lose money don't speculate don't buy
stocks
like i don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper
when you go buy 20 worth of google stock
what do you
get you get a piece of paper back
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay i want something i can see would
you agree
okay i would rather have that that money
i'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars i'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and i'm gonna buy a flip
charge
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if i use it
everybody agree okay so i want you to
write this down quit saving money
[Music]
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the wall
street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
ill-liquid and you do not want to save
money you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life i have had
to give up something i wanted
i'm not talking about getting rid of the
bad stuff you got to get rid of
something that you actually worked for
to get
it might have been the house
it might have been oh my kids are in the
best schools now it's going to be
something painful for you to get to the
next place you have to give up something
that you worked for really really hard
so i sold my house one day i had this
cognition hey to get what you want you
have to give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life i had to leave lake charles
louisiana went went to houston had to
leave houston once i got comfortable
with my community and my friends had to
leave san diego had to go to l.a l.a is
a pit
compared to la jolla nobody goes from la
jolla california up to los angeles
nobody does that you'll leave kansas
city to go to los angeles
because you want to be an actor i met
elena within five minutes of arriving in
l.a
i sold my house i sold my house i didn't
leave it vacant
as a backup plan i left this house okay
like i couldn't buy this house today if
i wanted to it was so like it was a
precious little treasure
i had to give that up by the way i had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me there wasn't a
restaurant i couldn't walk into i could
always get a seat i could always get the
best seat i had it right in my hand this
is what i'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life
that you're going to consult that
everybody's going to consult every one
of you are going to hey what do you
think should i
you better have that person on your side
in my case i was by myself
so my consultant was like you going to
do this dog i called my buddy dale dale
you think i should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what what do you have to risk
sold the house went to los angeles lived
in a hotel i went from a a house on the
ocean to living in a hotel the hotel
room was probably like i don't know
maybe the size of this stage
so please please do whatever you got to
do this weekend to figure out whatever
you got to do to get rid of whatever is
holding you back most of which is
something you worked hard to get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it i'm 63 years old you know i'll be 64
in march and
you know i feel like i'm like 14 years
old man i'm like let's roll like let's
let's go i'm ready to run through walls
and
you know fly and learn new stuff i'm
studying uh kryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do i make a play and do i make a play
and what is all this
so you one number one you have to stay
curious
[Music]
number one curious you have to be
curious when clubhouse came around
clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple of years ago most of the people
in my office including jared's like man
ain't nothing there's nothing there
you know i'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what i
discovered because i was curious about
clubhouse is not because i was curious
about social media i was curious about
people
to me i get energy from people
and so
i've been in rooms where
alan have y'all met alan yet
so alan allen saw me go in a room one
night and he text me he's like what the
hell you doing in this room man and i
said what's up he's like get out of this
room
and i said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
[Music]
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
i said bro where how am i going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks
just because it has nothing to do with
you doesn't mean your market's not there
and for me to be able to market to a
market
means i need to understand how that
market thinks so one of the great
benefits of me being curious
particularly about two-way communication
on social media the feedback
i'm not looking for likes and comments
i'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential an idea like all my ideas come
from i don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
i don't i don't create anything i just
grab something that's already there
and i grab it out of something i hear
so the supreme court today announced
they kicked out the mandate uh for the
vaccine i'm like hey man
okay good you like it or don't like it
y'all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh i don't want to
be political
say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam
and everybody knows that they're like
i'm throwing in they ain't throwing in
for their side they're throwing in to
keep the other side that they're worried
about
the point of the story is there's energy
there
there's tremendous amounts of energy
that you want to you want to tap into if
you could walk the line and play both of
them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today i'm like
good job man like i got to take a stand
on that now will i lose some people 100
percent
i don't care who i lose there's 8
billion people on this planet
i'm worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it
that's the only way to protect your
brand you know i'm always keeping it
real with you what has happened to our
country that we make our idols and our
icons and our heroes rappers and
entertainers and ball players and then
we showed disgust
for a businessman that can bank 50
million a year or 20 million a year what
is wrong look when a guy can go out and
make passive investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good investments
and bad investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year
making great investments great decisions
showing leadership in the marketplace
look that marketplace out there that
economy is the most savage
most difficult
playing field in the world to negotiate
yet
who do we admire in our culture rock
stars look these guys got great skills
kid gets out of school makes 12 million
a first year and we make posters of them
and sweatshirts
and and you put their kids in their
jerseys what about the business people
that make our economy work to pay the
taxes that make the schools work the
churches work that make the the fire
department the police department because
they pay taxes because they're out there
making great investments look admire
business people they're able to bank
year after year admire these people
study them learn from them don't be
disgusted with them and turn off anybody
anybody that would suggest to you that
making money in this country is wrong
look don't envy business people admire
them emulate them learn from them
particularly these guys are doing it
year after year after year not just on
income but on wealth development because
that's where you need to be that's where
you need to be thinking that's the
economy you want to create for yourself
your family your household and your
future man did you hear that the the
person that won the lottery i got two
points to make here the person that won
the lottery is 84 years old her name is
gloria mc mckenzie
here in florida she'll pay no state
taxes on that winning i keep telling you
guys move to a tax-free state so that
your income's not taxed and hey if you
win the freaking lottery
380 million freaking dollars
you wouldn't be taxed at 10 or 13
percent what are you thinking man the
second point here is this
this woman would not have won this
lottery ticket had it not been for the
guy in front of her being so gracious to
look at 84 and say hey lady you want to
go in front of me i guess he was worried
that she'd die before she could buy the
ticket okay folks in my book called if
you're not first your last
i basically explain
look man if you're first in line you
don't give it up to an 84 year old i
know that might sound you know without
compassion and and uncaring and not
sensitive
hey when you're buying a lottery ticket
get in get out as quick as possible if
you're not first your last in this case
i hope 84 gives this guy a little
squeeze of the cheese please
let's find out how gracious 84 is with
her 380 to the guy that got out of line
to get her in the line
to buy the ticket that won the money
where she don't pay any state taxes in
florida
showing up means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand doesn't mean you came to
work
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool
being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up
my body went in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
means you show up for the class you show
up for the homework you show up for the
class you show up for the homework you
show up for the test you freaking get a
perfect grade means you keep showing up
to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success so you got
to keep showing up showing up means
you're looking for deeper levels to show
up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what what's it why did
somebody pick that up
who's that new person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you nothing
and it makes all the difference but it's
showing up you'll see things that no one
else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just gotta make
a commitment to show up my wealth
ultimately is not the money i have it's
the knowledge i have
and the belief i have in myself the same
thing for you
but i want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it
you know in the physical universe you
can explain to me what a bougainvillea
is you can explain to me what a beach is
you can explain to me what
uh the gym looks like on the second
floor in cabo san lucas at this
beautiful hotel we're at but
until i visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales
to the sunshine to the mountains until i
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
i was i was doing a call today with
percy miller uh master p and he's like
first thing you got to do is see it in
your mind he grew up in extreme poverty
in the projects and he says grant first
thing i had to do was i had to see it
in my mind that i could get out second
thing i had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical universe
that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip
you can see the possibility of elon
going to mars you know and and all of a
sudden all those things expand
possibilities so number one you got to
see it in your mind too you got to see
it in the physical universe and this
also includes other people examples of
other people that are doing great things
i'm not just talking about physical
manifestation i'm not talking about
stuff
i'm not talking about watches and
bracelets and rings and houses and cars
i'm talking about how can you actually
manifest something in the real world
that you have in your mind how do you
turn an idea
into reality
and uh these things that i'm sharing
with you will make i'll make it a
possibility uh when you dig deep on them
though it's like okay well how do i get
closer to people that are doing those
things because the third thing is you
got to get closer to the thing you want
if you want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem on planet earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company an airport and
actually fuel them clean them wash them
maybe you got to be a flight attendant
on them put your feet next to them maybe
you have to become a pilot you're going
to have to pay the price though there's
no free lunch here for anybody including
my children there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at it on the internet
the moment you can get in it it'll be
become even more real to you the fourth
thing is you got to put your feet in
this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there i
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse
you you got to touch the horse and the
fourth thing i'm sorry you got to touch
the hearts and the fourth thing is you
guys got to collaborate with other
people man you got to get in the room
with other people whether you're serving
water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um
offer to serve them to sit down okay
there's a story in my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse
on the internet in a magazine a picture
of it third get closer to it put your
feet on it on the plane on the horse on
the beach in the hotel if i got to go
work there to do it and the fourth thing
is
you gotta network with people that have
stuff okay
again uh i spent some time this week
with uh dame dash she's like look you
gotta get close to the action you got to
get with the people that are making the
moves you cannot make the moves from
your own neighborhood uh percy miller
told me you cannot make the moves from
the projects you got to move from the
projects not make the moves in the
project quit working street corners
quit selling just a product and start
hanging out with people that have scaled
their think
their ideas
into a reality you have to prepare for
inflation hitting you
and
look i just want to give you a heads up
on this thing it's happening right now i
believe we're already in a recession not
to be a doomsday guy because i think
that there's ways for you to take
advantage of this but i just passed one
two three four five six shops and
nobody's in them
so the american consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand
not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing
uh the mass media to actually distribute
the bad news and we're not talking about
you crane and cobid we're not talking
about abortion
rulings because all that is just
distraction for the bigger problem which
is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the fed pushing interest rates
a half a point yesterday
there was a rebound in the stock market
this morning i wake up
the stock market rolls over by a
thousand points okay there's going to be
blood in the market so i'm going to do a
training on this i'm going to give you a
few tips right now but i'm going to
click i'm going to give you a link to a
training for those of you who actually
want to do something about this and not
just hear the bad news and be woken up
first thing is you got to wake up you
got to wake up to what's happening you
got to know that hey
what do i do now what do i do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you gotta expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do
uh you've heard of wealthy people doing
this before how they take advantage of
situations okay i'm going to show you
how to do that whether you have cash or
no you don't have cash whether you have
credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in america
many of you are going out trying to
start a new business where what you
ought to do is just kind of slide
sideways and go buy one the neighbor
next door to you i mean from laundry
mats to plumbers to internet businesses
to coaching businesses you name it
chiropractors dentists like in every
sector that you're involved in right now
in your business or your interest or
your passion i'll promise you
there are
thousands
thousands not one or two but thousands
of small businesses like yours
that are similar to your passion that
would feed your passion that already
have branding already have marketing
built in already have a name already
have a location already have revenue
already have credit lines that you can
literally just slide into
okay but you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that if all
you're doing is buying into bad news
so number one you can't buy into the bad
news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
is beat out by the need to survive and
the economy to go on the economy will
always go on
okay not just here in america but around
the world always always always we always
get on the other side of bad news so the
first thing you do is you got to keep
your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive
people always like oh yeah i can stay
positive on my own probably not because
you're not going to be on your own
you're going to be surrounded by bad
news everywhere so number two you got to
think about how do you expand despite
the fact that you don't have money and
you don't have credit or you do have
money and you do have credit but you
don't want to use either one because
you're terrified and you will be
the third thing you have to figure out
to do okay is exactly what sectors will
survive
long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction
what happens is weak businesses get
squeezed out weak names get squeezed out
okay a weak operators get squeezed out
and the strong come in and take over
that either the technology takes over
and disrupts a space or a person
typically a person or an operator comes
in and then scales that business
now what i'm going to look to do here in
the next couple years is actually
accelerate my expansion
accelerate my expansion because i know
how to operate i know the four things
you have to do in a business to make a
business successful there's only four
things you must do to keep a business
one profitable two expanding and three
flourishing
there's four things and only four things
okay i don't have time right now because
i'm with my family uh but but when you
click the link below what i'll do is
i'll give you a free training on those
four things that you have to do look you
will get through this i promise you're
gonna get through this the question is
you're gonna get through it and you're
gonna do great you're gonna flourish and
prosper you're gonna be like these
businesses waiting waiting
for traffic last thing i'm gonna tell
you is this
okay
don't
get
stuck in mechanics
when i'm writing my goals down i do not
know how i'm going to do it
so i merely sit down like i remember for
years i would write down i own a
helicopter i don't even know where this
concept came from i own a helicopter i
own a helicopter i own a helicopter
every once in a while it would show up
it would show up on a wednesday and not
show up for uh when i'm writing my goals
down right so i'm waking up in the
morning i wake up in the morning and i
write my goals down and one day i write
i own a helicopter
i think back then it was i learned how
to fly a helicopter
okay it was stupid it was completely
ridiculous i'm like where'd that come
from
it just kind of floated into my mind i
wrote it down okay i own a jet
i'm like man i'm just being stupid right
now i own a jet and two helicopters
i don't know how that happened i didn't
i didn't know anything about jets
uh i would not achieve any of this by
the way until i was
53 years old 54 years old
the first private jet i was ever on was
the one
we bought
i didn't know anything about it i didn't
know how they fly i didn't know how they
work i didn't know what the cost of a
hangar was i know nothing don't get lost
in the mechanics i didn't know the fuel
cost i didn't know what it cost to buy
one do you finance them do you pay cash
do you get a tax rate i knew nothing
when i started writing this down the
helicopter would come after the jet okay
i bought a helicopter i didn't know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start zip zip zip zip zip
you right through them like this morning
i wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public i write down one word i'm
going public
see i know now that this this is in
present tense and or past tense i write
it in present or past tense i'm going
public okay i wrote down recently uh a
congressional hearing
people like what what's a congressional
hearing dude i'm so big now they called
me into congress
they're going to have a congressional
hearing they're gonna drill me
okay oh yeah then i wrote this down
a political office
now i don't know why
i don't know why i'm writing that down i
don't know how to achieve that i don't
know what it would mean i don't know
what it looks like i don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it
commit first man just keep committing it
keep fueling and keep writing it down
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the one-on-one i did
recently with grant check it out right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there true wealth cannot be created
working it can only be created investing
elon musk is completely invested
he has no cash and no houses